hi guys today I'm going on a hot date ah
but say I'm not ready for a date you
don't think this is how I would look on
a date well you're probably right I just
wanna get ready for my date tonight one
second and it's just grab whatever
makeup I could find you like my green
eyes can you see they're green ok
already know my date tonight is with the
most adorable thing that I've ever set
my eyes on and I very excited for it can
you guess what it is I'm sure most if
you'd probably guess what it is I might
even have it in the title anyway this is
my hot day named Ethan I mean wait I
didn't read that ha what's your own name
I mean Oh God it's okay I'm just as bad
as you my name is yak man
no X because that's just a kiss yeah
come on serious it doesn't even sound
like a name it's not so i can't really
mean um yo I'd say the same to you could
i I don't understand straight talk
another do I we've got something in
common ground to start on oh well why
would I even say these words to this I
don't know I didn't meanings that Street
talk do you have any special skills I
believe I could hold a high level of
commercial awareness which helps me
achieve profitable growth in a
convention something I'm also sick a
triple jump let me see it and uh uh uh
but I would probably only you would know
yes I won't trust me there are those
that are born with one purpose one fake
I'm amongst them okay whatever you say I
can't move all your name is pinky that's
your name Woods would you like to hear a
joke
a joke good one no I haven't told her
yet yeah exactly what do you get when
you cross the jet with a rhetorical
question what have you told that in
public before I was afraid time to turn
the future good lord he's a like me what
are you thinking I asked that question
there lots of people at the like nothing
my head is a wasteland a thoughtless voy
a vacuum but vacuums tu veux up thoughts
and echoing chasm of oblivion Wow okay
then that was a mood killer wasn't it
half I guess this is goodbye okay bye I
was on the speed dating my name is
fitted for the pay can we just something
name yeah okay oh oh I didn't even write
my name no I'm code nothing what are you
afraid of I'm not afraid of anything
except violinists obviously why that's
cine that kind of goes without saying
what are you afraid of I am afraid of my
feet being touched it's true buy
anything stones sand aren't we all
afraid of my fee being touched yes so no
we're not I've never heard of anyone say
that Oh what would you superpower me I
always picture myself as a geometric
laser beam crime crusher with fresh
never morals I can just see it now cool
Oh goodbye I never want to see you again
you were mean to me nice one take care o
doing I don't really care exactly see
hey dude people call me Douglas what up
what's your name my name is young man
o-neck sense well don't what it hey why
are you're so rude to me let's see what
if I'd be really nice to you lovely
lovely lovely dovely love me lovely now
love me okay do you live around here why
are you planning on following me home
and having your name into my head well
yes well I'm glad good I'm glad you're
glad I'm 30
you believe in Star Wars thing called
love no star wars ever since i
experienced it with my app you
experience no I'm not touching you ah I
agree with you Oh Brady I was just
kidding o.o grade okay turn good oh no
what are you thinking about you ah yay
carving my name in your head oh oh this
perilous serve me so how's the handle
rejection and would you like to see my
collection of South porch oh ok time
over ah let's meet up again I told her I
roll why why I'm bedroom no me neither
you that's cute someone likes my name
this could be the one let's tell him he
looks lovely tell me something I don't
know Oh arrogance is not good thank you
for fun be inviting lessons to myself
for a long time waiting
what is wrong for you I made videos oh
this is exactly what people say d so
what do you do for fun I make videos oh
that's my life right there that's
exactly how it goes have you always been
that high that's what people usually ask
me it hasn't changed much so far I'm
satisfied with the current situation
well that's good it's something she's
happy with it I guess um George just you
took a little bit gosh like my boy thing
good that's actually the look I was
going for so thank you for noticing oh
well you're very welcome i'm glad that
you like your monkey boy face I've my
quite awkward do you have a happy place
no I no no yes Oh only anguish and
suffering oh wow that was that a very
good way to end things I had a great
time I'm sure you did I make great
company all screwy
I'm not impressing anyone of these it's
just get this over and over the pay i'm
barbara i doubt haha i thought like that
the thing from french at i'm gonna watch
our name oh my god where's the name of
it elsker is barbarella now all right up
yeah i was serious i doesn't even sound
like a name whatever what do you do for
fun look young man i'm right which i
should djing really hurted not that
you're gonna say that okay mr. DJ or
miss DJ I dinner yeah we'll never have
guessed oh but yeah as well so I do fun
oh oh I I code stuffs i turn the most
now your lifestyle
did you like to see my selection of news
ah oh I'm sure we gonna get a collective
movie oh do you know I wouldn't see your
collection of our fitness I'm oddly
getting along with Barbara it's going
well oh I guess this is goodbye yeah
lets me huh because you were cool I
hardly know that was the wrong spelling
of knew there wasn't it I were my name's
Neil can we just get the server with
let's totally fly with this one and see
if we can get him to like it you want to
take us on a second date you look lovely
oh you I woke up like this nothing as
okay let's give them something cool what
wedding um it's things sometimes yeah
like that sweet Gianni Nick
am I oh so he's the Riddler disguise you
will never know the real TJ oh oh I just
you just told me oh oh sorry I'm so I'm
sorry um I'm to win it back now um what
is your favorite vegetable I what a
great question my fav is a noise will be
lettuce good choice on their mind is
broccoli so much better are you having
you next time on ax CMT for to answer oh
I'm boring him oh do you like me of
course who do you take me for yeah um do
you ever have place my happy voices
within sleep in the annals of my
consciousness it's a place annals emails
to state of mind deep I guess this is
goodbye okay what's he gonna say um
that's it I'm done none of these bugs
like me they're also attractive just
look good enough for any of them up
enjoy this video please give it a thumbs
up if you enjoyed the links in the
description for you to have your own pub
date maybe they like you more than they
like me how do I dare evening
please pretty don't kill me who said I
was going to kill you mm-hmm what I want
you to do I won't kill you dearie I just
wanted to talk to you uh okay